hello this is presh talwalkar
your credit card number probably looks
pretty random to you
but hidden inside those digits is a
secret mathematical code
in this video i'll teach you a magic
trick based on the pattern
you'll need a credit card a debit card
or an atm card that has 16 digits
you also want some pencil and paper to
do some simple calculations
for this video i'm going to do the
calculation for the number that's
written on the screen but you should
follow along with your own credit card
number
to get started focus on the 16 digits in
the number
and separate them into two groups
for the first step add up every other
digit
in this case the digits which are
colored in black
we'll add up 1 3 5 7 8 0 zero and zero
to get to a sum of twenty four
we'll go ahead and double this result
twenty four times two is forty eight
now look at the numbers which you've
just added up
count the number of digits which are 5
or larger
in this case the numbers 5 7 and 8 are 5
or larger
so that means there are 3 numbers which
are 5 or larger
finally
add up the remaining digits
these are the digits which are colored
in blue
two four six eight nine zero zero and
zero
this gives the sum of twenty nine
now we're ready to do the magic part
we have three numbers 48 3 and 29
when we add up these three numbers we're
going to end up with the number whose
last digit is zero
and this is true for every single credit
card number
so that's the magic part you can have
someone do this they'll do these
calculations and you're gonna say all
right look at your number the last digit
is zero
you might be wondering why this works
this in fact is a mathematical code that
is programmed into your credit card
number
the reason it's in there is because if
you've ever typed your credit card
number into a website and you've
accidentally typed in the wrong number
the website doesn't know it needs to
know how to validate a correct number
from an incorrect number so this is one
way that they track that you've typed in
a credit card number that's valid
if you end up with a sum whose last
digit is not zero
then that means you probably typed in
your credit card number incorrectly
so it's a pretty neat magic trick and
someone who doesn't know that this is
encoded in the magic in the credit card
number is going to be surprised you knew
the last digit of this number is zero
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mindyourdecisions which you can
follow on facebook google plus and
patreon
you can catch me on social media at
preshtalwalker
and please check out my books i've
written a detailed description of each
one in the description for this video